last night aw dynamite christian cage's
first real singles wrestling match in
seven years i saw the reception online
was
phenomenal fans really seemed to enjoy
it i really enjoyed it
could you tell me a little bit about
what it was like to get back in there
and how would you grade your own
performance versus frankie kazarian
yeah so uh it felt great to get back in
there honestly it's a little surreal
to kind of had to pinch myself right
before i went out there
you know one thing that kind of just
came to me as i went out there
i stepped through those ropes and i
kissed the ring you know and that was
kind of a symbol of like you know taking
back what i'd lost seven years ago
and um it was like coming home as soon
as i stepped
foot those ropes it all comes back
you know that nothing can replicate no
matter how much training you put in
um nothing can replicate getting in
there and doing it for real
so it was a real test and it was it was
a test against
myself and against frankie and you know
against all these these factors of
coming back after such a long layoff
um but i i i'm always my toughest critic
so i will grade i give myself a b plus
yeah so but uh you know frankie is
outstanding
um i really wanted him to be my first
opponent i'm glad
that it did end up being him i think uh
much like me i've kind of been painted
with the brush of being
quote-unquote underrated people have
told me that all the time that
you're underrated you're one of the most
underrated guys ever which is great to
hear my response is always better be
underrated than overrated
but uh to me i look at a guy like
frankie and frankie
is legit and underrated talent and i
i wanted to go out there and as much for
me i want to go out there and prove
um or remind people just how good he is
uh and i think that we uh both elevated
each other win or lose
agreed uh this isn't the first time that
you have
departed from the wwe you did so back in
2005 with tna you felt a little
pigeonholed
you go there become the world champion
and really elevate your status
here we are a decade and a half later
same theme song
different christian cage can you sort of
juxtapose those two journeys because at
the time you were
you know you still had a lot of
potential and here you are as a veteran
who's accomplished just about everything
in the sport
right so the first time i left and sorry
if there's some background noise there's
some uh
landscapers up there cutting grass uh
not sure if you have that issue in
canada right now with snow or not
uh down here it's sunny a lot of rain in
vancouver but i feel for my toronto
brethren
yeah the um but um
the yeah so in when i left in 2005 it
was more to bet on myself and to prove a
point
um i felt like i was stuck in a rut i
felt like i needed to get away
in order to come back and be better than
i was i needed to step away and prove
um that i could work and wrestle at the
top of the card and carry a show
and i felt like um if i just stayed in
wwe that
i wasn't necessarily going to get that
opportunity no matter what reactions or
the quality
of matches that i was putting on so i
needed to kind of bet on myself
get out of their face for a little while
go and prove it even if it was on a
smaller scale that i could do that and i
feel like i did
um and then i came back this time is a
little bit different
um i didn't leave wwe because i wasn't
under contract with w
i hadn't been under contract with wwe in
probably six
seven years at this point in time so um
it was a choice
that i made i needed the best platform
for me at this stage in my career where
i felt like i'd go out and do
my best work and also elevate the next
generation that's
coming up behind me i love that
and you mentioned that you weren't under
contract the wwe this time uh you made
your return the royal rumble
you had to retire because of concussion
related issues
you went and saw specialists on your own
you were totally cleared
do you have to adapt or change how you
compete in the ring just to be
aware of the fact that this is something
you've had to deal with in the past
um you know what i thought that um so i
went and got cleared on my own and then
um
you know wwe sent me two specialists in
pittsburgh and i went
with like a really um
in-depth five-hour
testing for these concussions i saw
three or four different specialists
you know i went in the gym and i did
like a full 45-minute workout for them
it was it was very thorough
and both the doctors said the same thing
in particular the doctor that i saw in
pittsburgh after the tests
he said i need you to go in the ring if
you're going to do this and not worry
about getting concussed again
because if you have anxiety about it if
it's present in your mind if it's what
you're thinking about that you're going
to get hurt when you get in there you're
making yourself more susceptible to it
you have to go in there with all the
confidence in the world that you're just
as good as you've ever been
and as far as all these tests go and all
the conversations and everything that
we've done here
you're at no greater risk than you were
at any other point in your life with
this happening again could it happen
again
sure but you're not at any bigger risk
so that just
all the confidence that i needed and
honestly i i haven't even thought about
it not once
well sorry to remind you but i'm happy
to hear that
but it's it's part of my journey we have
to talk about it completely fine
well and speaking of your journey i
don't know if there's a better story of
friendship in pro wrestling than edge
and christian
childhood friends you get into this
industry together and it's remarkable
because when you guys are together
you're one of the most prolific tag
teams in the sport
but when you're on your own the
parallels have been super interesting
edge is the champion in one organization
christian's a champion and another
um have you guys had a chance to talk
about this most recent
era where you are now on in a sense
counter programming both in sort of a
main event slot
yeah well we haven't really sat down and
discussed that um
you know obviously when i was making my
decision to go to aw
obviously you know i did talk to him
about it and told him you know where my
head was at what i was going to do and
of course
what you do when you're best friends you
support each other no matter what and he
understood that
that we both have some things that we we
want to accomplish
and we also understand that um
you know you have to go where you're
best served like i said that platform to
do what it is that you want to do
with the to be honest here we're both
close to the end of our careers we both
thought they were over but at this point
you know we are on limited time so we
have to maximize that time
and that's kind of just really the only
conversations that we've had about it
did you have a chance to get his
thoughts on your match on wednesday
yeah i did actually um so uh
he's actually staying at my house
yeah because uh you know obviously uh
smackdown and raw are here
in temp we watched it together and uh um
yeah i mean he was he was very happy
with
for me and and was very complimentary of
it of course we uh
you know we always both kind of nitpick
uh give each other constructive
criticism and those sorts of things but
uh
i think for the most part you felt the
same way that i did i don't think it
could have gone better for the first one
back
good to hear now you know pro wrestling
is where your head is at right now but
you are one of the guys who have
successfully made the transition to
the wider entertainment sphere whether
it's haven
or cage fighter but there's one that
really sticks out of my mind and that is
murdoch mystery something that yeah
canadian as denim jeans and hockey
can you tell me a little bit about what
it was like to be on the set oh it was
unbelievable
yeah i really had a great time it was
one of those shows that i that i watched
down here
in florida and it's all mordock
mysteries now but for the longest time
it was on
um it was on like an art channel like a
really
small channel that you had to have like
900 channels on your cable to
this this one particular channel and it
was they changed the name of it to the
artful detective
so that's what it was called here yeah
and for a few years now it's whatever
whatever channel it's on now it's called
mirage mysteries again but
um yeah uh it was it was it was a lot of
fun and uh
when i got the chance to do the audition
for that show i was very excited and it
was obviously a role that i felt like i
could play
a heavyweight boxer um the heavyweight
champion of toronto so it was it was
very cool but to go
go there and hang out on the set and um
you know the way they built the streets
of toronto uh
to to that time period was really
impressive
and uh everyone was great and i just had
a great time and i
i wish it wasn't just a one-off i would
have loved to have done done more who
know
some point i'll get that opportunity
again but i really enjoy that show so it
was a thrill for me to do it
well that's a perfect segue because i
was going to ask what other roles in
hollywood are you still interested in
occupying in the future
yeah i mean anything that you know it's
i just like the challenge you know and
that was one of the things too when i
stepped away from the ring
um you know we're artists in a sense we
like to create
rate of mind and you know you can tell
those stories
um in the ring so what's it you're
trying to find a different creative
outlet you know so which like you know
we moved on to the edge and christian
show that we wrote and produced
the wwe network or the podcast that uh
the enc's part of awesomeness you're
just trying to find different ways
uh to be creative so i never want to
kind of they don't put myself in one box
and just say okay i'm an actress i know
that i'm
i'm not but i was you know working
towards and that was a thrilling thing
for me too was you know much when i got
in
like when i got into wrestling um trying
to get better
every day and working with people that
were better than you in their brains and
that's
what excited me about acting was working
with real actors
and working with people that were much
better than i was and
getting to pick their brain or just sit
on the sidelines and watch them do a
scene of
what it was that they were doing but
like honestly i would love to do a
dramatic role
i would love to do something box off
they wouldn't expect
a professional wrestler to be able to do
um
with something with some depth and some
layers a real
a real drum i would love to do that
we're on the same page christians
as we start to wrap up here you know i
think there was a time where the idea of
a pro wrestler in hollywood was
you know a gimmick more of a token thing
a novelty act
you've got dwayne johnson who's a legit
leading man john cena who's crafting
this great nation comedy of course dave
batista
starred in everything from james bond to
guardians of the galaxy
who of those you know new crop of
wrestlers turned actors is your favorite
and why
i mean well they're all talented in
their own way but i i think
dave batista really brings something
different to each one of his roles like
his range is what's impressed me more
than anything
that the range that he can bring to
every single role and that he can
only has the ability to suck the
audience in almost you know he he can
he can talk late he can be believable in
any role that he's not that the other
guys aren't it's just i don't know it's
hard to put my finger on it but
something about i just find range is
incredible
and that's so impressive to me
you